allowing yourself to fail is the secret
sauce right because you experiment you
you only learn from failing by the way
you don't learn from successes because
it works what do you learn
when you lose and you try to understand
or you fail you try understand what went
wrong and then you find a way to solve
it you know and then
you so you do it okay so even if things
doesn't work for the first time it will
work in the second time but then you you
can actually get there if you don't try
you won't get there welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
let's talk about autonomous vehicles and
what is enabling autonomous vehicles
today we are with enemies and we are
going to meet over kayla co-founder and
ceo of innovas technologies a leading
provider of lidar sensing solutions mr
kaloff is helping to enable the mass
commercialization of autonomous vehicles
and under his leadership the company has
won a program with bmw for the
industry's first series production of
autonomous vehicles as well as a number
of partnerships with leading tier 1
solution providers prior to co-founding
innovates omer served as an officer in
the elite technological unit of the
intelligence corps of the israel defense
forces unit 81 and held senior
leadership roles in various companies
omar holds a bsc and msc in electrical
engineering and an mba all from the
talbot university
omela welcome to 20 minute leaders
nice to meet you thank you very very
much for hosting me here
obviously we're not in my regular studio
and we're not in a traditional office
space
where are we right now
uh we are in the innoviz garage this is
where we have several cars here
uh where we test the technology for
autonomous cars
okay so we're talking about garage cars
autonomous vehicles i wish you know one
day
that i could have cars with my logo on
them in my own office but your wish is
my command okay there you go we have it
on record but yeah you know five years
ago you'll need to buy a bmw so yes
you won't get it for me
five years ago yeah you had a vision
you saw the real division by the way
three three oh there you go you saw the
world and where we're heading with
autonomous vehicles and and you know we
don't have to go in and describe what
autonomous vehicles is i think enough
people know it by now but you're
creating a technology that enables it
and is pushing the world forward making
it actually a possibility and i would
love to hear a little bit about this
journey and a little bit about your own
vision and i want you to take me back
you know before we even talk about
innoviz take me back to to you and what
made what led to your conviction that
this is a company that you want to build
and how you use that vision to
strategically point you all the way up
to
making it a public company yeah okay so
actually i can start by saying that
when i was looking to start my own
company i had
you know
more than one idea okay i had like
actually 20 something
different startups that i was kind of
collecting ideas through the years
and and i always knew that i would pick
up a certain you know
a path where i'll be become you know an
entrepreneur
and going through this how early did you
know that you want to be an entrepreneur
i think uh
you know i my my background is i was in
a unit 81 which is a very technical kind
of a very inspiring place very creative
very creative and it's
always even there it's like always about
bringing very new technologies in a very
short time
and
the methodologies at the school i come
from it comes from a lot of uh
you know how to develop new technology
in a very short time and managing risks
et cetera and it's about making the
right decision at the right time and
sometimes some and even taking some
risks um
but uh
what the slogan of that unit is about
capabilities
uh
passion and commitment you know that's
kind of like exactly what i
was looking for uh when i started a new
you know company of myself i was looking
for something that i can do
that can actually bring everything all
together and once you are engaged with a
technology that is life-saving and you
know how critical it is
uh it it really you know connects
everything i so i want to pause on this
for a second because you're describing
this technology first as life-saving now
i think that when you talk about
autonomous vehicles in the in the public
mindset today and if i look at the
headlines
very rarely do i see the term
life-saving i see better for fuel
consumption i see you know you don't
need
drivers anymore you can do your emails
but you're talking about life-saving
tell me a little bit about that yeah
definitely i mean if you think about
mobility
and that's something that we do on on a
daily basis i mean every day we drive
somewhere because we have to it's part
of our life
and basically
that is still possibly the most risky
action you do on a daily basis
which you know we are all part of right
i was driving a motorcycle once many
years ago
and after two or three years i decided
to stop and i remember when i decided to
stop i felt that i was lucky you know
wow i felt that i was managing to escape
the statistics you know because every
every driver a motorcycle driver
understand that it's under a huge risk
we as a as a you know car the drivers we
know that it's a risk we feel it less
but it's obviously
still the biggest problem we you know we
face on a daily basis
80 to 90 of the accidents are still
caused by human
and and that's a problem that could be
solved and by the way you know most of
the accidents you know they happened due
to uh human destruction right and and
and over confidence that we have as
drivers we drive on the road we become
bold we see that you know that it's
empty and we think that we get it you
know we got it you know
we manage it and you know we look at the
phone and you know in a second something
happens and you know solving that
problem uh
is already available i mean that the
technology is now i'm talking about
today is already there it's only about
now it's mostly engineering it's not
kind of but you know five years ago uh
there was a gap i mean there was a real
gap in technology to to allow it to
happen and that's what made me devote my
older sister
she got into a very serious accident
when i was a kid
and it completely
changed the you know the life of my
family you know my mother stopped
working my father was for me i mean
she was in a hospital for a year and a
half
so obviously when you're seeing uh the
you know what happens when when
someone's just injured
you know uh and how it affects so many
people around him
and
you know it's uh
we have to solve it right i mean corona
changed our life and everybody was uh
not accepting it you know nobody
accepted that our life changed but we're
we're actually accepting for many years
a hundred years now that it's okay that
every year you have two million people
killed and 20 or 50 million
wow and like i don't know between 10 20
and 50 million people are injured every
year wow and we
nobody is
you know you know with corona people
were
you know asking when is the solution is
going to come you know everyone's
waiting for the next vaccine to come and
you know we were all wishing it will
come but nobody is waiting and i'll stay
where's the protest around my office you
know yeah make it happen already you
know i i want the people
to to be to say okay i i you know i'm i
was
i mean i escaped the statistics right i
don't need to drive anymore because it's
safer because eventually you know
machines will be able to drive much
better than than the driver right it's a
and it's almost there
now if you look back five years
you're just starting out
you know as an entrepreneur and you so
you have this you know intrinsic
motivation based on also personal
experience but you're also understanding
the bigger gap
this is before also you know the the the
analogy the comparison to corona i mean
this is obviously you know we know where
the world is headed what do you set out
for yourself what is sort of the goal
that you say to yourself this is what i
want to achieve as an entrepreneur in
this domain
well you can't imagine how the world
would look like five years later like i
i don't think i could imagine like where
we are today but
the thing that drew me to this startup
is also because you know i was looking
to do something that i thought that have
i have some personal advantage
you know for my background and the
technology you know there are many ideas
i was thinking about but i couldn't
convince myself
that
i can do this better than anyone else
right i mean it's a good idea someone
should do it i'm not sure it's me i'm
not sure that
eventually
a bottom line uh i bring all of the
needed experience and knowledge in that
specific field that will make me
successful as someone else and i was
looking for something that i do have an
edge
and specifically in in our technology
there there are many cutting
technologies inside but actually in some
that i have actually a lot of experience
with and that's what
allowed me uh to eventually bring such a
cutting cutting edge technology and
i had uh i can give you an interesting
uh insight
history
we started innovas
and we raised money quite quickly and
based on the background of the founders
and really you know a growing market
but it was it went everything like very
very quickly
we didn't have really a a real
opportunity to talk with a customer
because you know when a car maker
wouldn't talk to uh you know
some young
excited entrepreneur and start to tell
him what you know what he's looking for
right
now we're talking about companies that
have hundreds of thousands of employees
yeah of course you know
like some companies like
gm and bmw like right you will never get
an access to talk with them to
understand really what they look for
right and
what the only thing we had to see
in order to understand what's already
available and kind of get a benchmark of
the market was a technology which was
really like very big and very expensive
and we thought that if we will make
that smaller and cheaper we will solve
the problem
because everybody will only talking
about price like price and size and
reliability and we knew how to solve
that problem but once we started to talk
with customers and that was only
possible when you were funded and like
our vcs actually opened up doors for us
to talk with them
and we told them about our plans
and they said look
the existing technology yes it's too
expensive and it's uh
unreliable but it's not good enough
we'll look for some we are looking for a
technology that can they need to solve
something much more difficult we need
much higher resolution we need much
higher a longer range and higher frame
rate and it was just to give you kind of
a reference it was like almost three
orders of magnitude
more difficult
and and we were
shocked you know like how how far
actually what we were thinking to do wow
and what the market is really really
needs
and
you can imagine uh how stressful that
was right yeah i mean three orders of
magnitude
now as
now i think the the the
the solution always comes in
in the way that a startup he needs to
make a decision on what product he is
going to develop but it's also very
important to understand
uh when
okay if if you're in a sense of urgency
you have to bring something to the
market next year
because the window of selection is done
in a year
it leaves you a certain time to develop
right but if you understand that you
know autonomous driving you know
eventually it's not next year it's
actually you know further ahead
you
you understand that you can plan
differently and you can go into a deeper
path in like a longer path in in
developing the right technology to solve
the problem right
and you should also be aware that you
shouldn't take too high of a risk
because you might go into trying to
develop something that is not possible
to solve i mean taking a technology that
will take you 20 years it's not good
enough so along these same lines you
know as a deep technologist
also a ceo you just came back from from
doing some amazing demos in new york for
a week and what i'm trying to now figure
out is
how do you balance being the engineer
you know the core engineer with the
cutting edge technology and at the same
time having to sell and partner with
some of the most complicated
organizations in the world
with hundreds of thousands of employees
and how do you know
when to go back and forth because
obviously there's implications and
there's opportunity costs for doing
either too late or too soon
so first off
we are an industry which is very
technical so my customers are not
they are doctors right they are optical
engineers and ai engineers and you need
to talk their language okay and when
they meet a ceo that is
marketing only marketing it's uh that
you won't go through
and you have to understand
their needs
and once uh these the you have alignment
on
the strategy meaning that you're solving
something they care about
you start to create those engagements
bmw uh is our first customer okay they
chose us for serious production
when we were less than a two years
company wow and that's probably
something they never done before yeah i
hope they will do it again
but they chose us
because um they trust they they believed
in astrology when we talk tell them
about what we want to develop and why
uh they agreed basically they agreed
that that's the way to solve the problem
because there are many ways and but they
agreed this is the right way and after a
year of due diligence talking with my
engineers yeah a year of due diligence
on a company that is two years old yeah
they they brought yes no look they
they came in uh to our offices we were
in closer not in this place we were a
smaller company
and they brought tens of engineers on a
weekly basis to really uh
you know go into our design and and you
know work with engineers to understand
our plans
because it's a big risk for them i mean
going to serious production is you know
for carmaker you know we all know about
adjusting time like that when a factory
is producing cars if there is anything
that slows it down because um
one piece of equipment that is is
missing is it catastrophe
it's like it's stopping it's millions of
dollars a day of loss and therefore
choosing a technology has to be with
very high risk management and
they chose us after
really a year of due diligence and
eventually got to a conviction that the
engineers are very capable and they can
deliver wow and that's what eventually
led to our nomination and since then we
are working with them and now we already
have the product i mean the product that
we were telling them about like
three and a half years ago like we had
nothing to show seriously is even
resembles really the product even i can
tell you that now we're working on our
second generation
it's 30 times better the than this one
okay which is already quite amazing and
you know i have a customer who is he
wants to use the next generation
he said look i you know until the
product will arrive i would like to use
in with one
i don't care because it's only for
testing and evaluation
build
help me
use several of those so i can
you know use it in the meantime like i
don't want to put a few of them on the
car
so i can gather something that simulates
how the next product would be and i'll
tell them look
you'll need to use 30.
it's 30. i mean
it's 30 times better it means you need
30 of those so you want to use 30 i'm
not sure
so
like it's kind of like amazing to see
how fast the technology how does this
impact you know this conviction so going
back to
bmw bringing tens of engineers to work
with your engineers and yourself
what does this do to the company culture
as your engineers are sitting in the
offices and they're getting this con
they're getting this approval in a
massive due diligence process from bmw
and the reason i'm asking this is
because we live in a generation now
where entrepreneurs are capable of
raising funds at a much easier rate than
before which means that oftentimes they
run quicker than the product is actually
being developed and i'm wondering maybe
there are some cases where people and
companies feel that the company isn't
isn't meeting the expectations of the
product that it's supposed to be doing
well which is not what what i'm hearing
here i i think that
one of the best things that happened to
this company is that we were over funded
at the beginning okay i was looking to
raise
i don't know 750 000 dollars
i closed the round of 9 million
wow okay
now you can imagine and
that it allowed us to do more
right and i can tell you that even when
we decided to raise more money we didn't
plan to raise nine and produce we plan
to raise four
and
what that gives you
is uh basically we had a plan
that met the four million dollars uh
spending
but since we have
more uh ability
in a way
we internally we talked about we have
three coins each one is one billion
dollar and we are going to make a bet on
a technology and i'm not talking about a
bit i'm obviously going into something
more risky in terms of whether it will
work eventually or not right but if it
will it will be a major uh acceleration
of the process
and we've done it on many fonts and all
of them succeeded you know it's it's
amazing because look when you have a
good engineering practice you you're not
really making bets you're just taking
more risk right exactly and and those
risks eventually allows you to run
faster yes after one year we were able
to bring a technology that was better
than many companies that were working
years before us and it was because we
were not afraid
to uh you know
to her say to fail you know so
we had nothing to lose right
you ran with the funds that a large
company would be able to put into a
project like this but with a startup
mindset and so you were able to run
faster these risks and amazing
allowing yourself to fail is the secret
sauce right because you experiment you
you only learn from failing by the way
you don't learn from successes because
it works right what do you learn
when you lose and you try to understand
or you fail you try understand what went
wrong and then you find a way to solve
it you know and then
you so you do it okay so
even if things doesn't work for the
first time it will work in the second
time but then you you can actually get
there if you don't try
you won't get there and i can tell you
that one of the
you know when i started and we found
that three orders of magnitude
difficulty you know there was a lot of
debate on how to how to tackle it uh
most of my comparators if not all they
were in the same position five years ago
and they decided to do something else
and they decided to do
um
something that is
as close as possible okay meaning that
okay we'll do something that is in
higher performance but never mind the
cost or
only doing something very cheap but the
performance is very poor
and
and they took the easy path because i
you know i could make the same decision
and i can tell that some in the some
people in the group thought that might
be the right thing because let's start
let's do something that is a higher
performance but we'll take care of the
cost later and i said look
if we do that
we might end up with a product that
you know
you can scale with right because it
doesn't really solve the problem so why
are we doing it yeah i mean i brought
the best engineers in israel to solve a
a problem not to do
i'm not a lighter company i'm not a lie
though i'm not selling lighthouse i'm
selling
a product for autonomous vehicles that
can enable you to scale that's what i do
if and i if i fail i will fail but if i
will succeed i made something meaningful
if i will try to do something that only
allows me to sell you know lidars in
maybe a different industry it's not
where i'm going this is why the
investors preempted and and requested to
be part of this vision because it's
pretty rare to meet somebody who's
saying i'm going all out i'm going for
the moonshot i think i can succeed but
hey we might fail but i'm gonna go for
the moonshot you're right but you have
to be but i can tell you there were
companies that were shooting for the
moon
and in a way after five years they
learned they have another 15 years ahead
of them
and they decided to stop because it's
also it's it's you have to be practical
right you can't there is a window where
you need to fit yeah
and you shouldn't over kind of overshoot
because you can go into a tunnel and
never go out okay
you need to be still in discussion and
an ability to access the market with a
product and improve it it's it's not
always it's never like it's like the
perfect you need to find the right fit
and that's a dialogue you continuously
do with the market
and understanding
what things you need to change over time
it's not like we had like after we did
that uh
you know we went into once realizing we
have that gap we went into a three or
four months of uh just brainstorming we
kind of you know looked of different
ways to solve it and eventually decided
but of course even when we launched the
the process
you always
you need to kind of be very sensitive
because understanding if the market is
pulled in or pulled out whether there
are new technologies whether more
opportunities so that's kind of like the
out right likely to always like being a
startup
is about taking risks but managing them
right stacking risk is just one part
managing those managing those risks is
the more important one right it's always
to be on guards and right anybody can
take a bet it's it's managing it's
managing the bet
this the small device generation one
student generation two
what what what is it what do you
actually do what is innovation you know
just a little bit this okay
um so you can see it's a
it's a it's a it's a device
that is uh looks like a small spaceship
yeah
it's a
very look nice looking you can hold it
it's very cool
so yes there are there are really a lot
of technologies that we had to develop
here i think that one of the parts that
looks like glasses like yeah it's a it's
uh it's an optical sensor yeah actually
so you know when we started
there was a lot of this a lot of
confusion about how what's the right way
to solve this problem
and really there are many
there are many ways to try to do it but
eventually you have to be very careful
with the pricing because automotive
is super sensitive to pricing yeah and
that's a problem you can't solve that's
the market that's the willingness to pay
you can do an amazing product but if it
doesn't fit
the pricing capabilities of
people
because most of the cars today and are
going to be still in the next 10 years
privately owned right okay and a person
needs to buy a car and you it can afford
buying a sensor that costs thousands of
dollars which means for you the
translation for you as an entrepreneur
means you have to develop a product that
won't impact the price of the end result
dramatically you need to understand the
willingness to pay off your customers
and it's very sensitive and again you me
and you can miss it by
you know slightly and it just doesn't
pass because in every car company that
uh there are you know commercial
engineers that all they do is calculate
uh the willingness of people to pay for
a central feature and if it's beyond
that they will not do it right they will
just wait out until it will be
affordable because otherwise they nobody
will buy it and they it will be they
will lose money so it's about
understanding uh the pricing pressure
and then we understand and we understood
of what kind of technologies could
eventually allow us to get there and of
course there was not nothing on the
shelf like we had to develop the entire
chipset that allowed us to to do a good
lighter if we had bars just bought
components of the shelf a laser a
detector and a and some of the other
electronics
you we will probably get where the
others you know yeah right and it's not
really solving the problem
so we had to go into very
the deep layers of the you know the
physics so this is designed and
manufactured by you and and more on the
impact of the design you yes exactly
we're not manufacturing it right we have
we have a production in germany we have
a production i mean yeah but eventually
the the design of the chips we have
three chips that we design here amazing
and in the following uh generation there
is another one actually we're changing
several of those it's
like innova is one which we designed for
bmw primarily you know it was under a
very uh clear mindset of a certain
timeline that we need to meet yeah so
it's once we were nominated it was about
delivering it was about execution it's
no longer like a research it's not a we
cannot go into a path where we don't
know whether we are able to meet it it's
like you're going to production yeah but
in the in meanwhile you are developing
the you're working on the
industrialization of the product
there are teams that are continuously
working on the next generation now
we
now we are now taking all of those uh i
would say uh
you know a new innovation and brought in
into the next product you know these two
and that's what's
allowing us to bring it not only 30
times better but also 70 percent cost
really
yeah it's a much cheaper product wow so
it allows also allowing us to be very
competitive
in even lower grade costs right i mean
not only the beginning exactly right
eventually you want to go
you want to scale to everything the
majority of private owners are owning
not bmw exactly unfortunately
unfortunately
maybe one day monday yeah amazing now
while we're talking about this i want to
also
make the you know
go back a little bit and understand you
with the personality going into going
into interviews you know so you were
always an engineer right
now what is what does it mean for you is
it were you an engineer when you started
81 were you an engineer before that in
your mindset
uh i was an engineer in 91
and i was an engineer after seven years
i left and i joined three startups in
israel
and most of my career i was acting as a
you know as an engineer in a kind of uh
like management in terms of leading but
i want to know about the mindsets yeah
but like when you were 10 11. were you
an engineer oh um
i don't know
i mean i was always very technical i
liked coding i i i teach myself coding
and
i enjoyed it very much i i was very much
in love with the topic
i actually went to study electric
engineering rather rather than
software development although that was
my initial passion because i was
i i saw that it's uh it gives me more
tools you know it's more tools to play
with that's what i love i really love
technologies that are very
multi-disciplinary where i can actually
try to solve a problem in many many ways
and find the right fit between them i
always say this technology is like a
spaghetti it's like uh
it's like super complicated there's so
much coupling between the different
components and
this is where i i think that is my
advantage in because i
you know i can i can bring the
integration all together and things to
operate together i think part of the
this also requires a very strong
collaboration between the team
because such you know components will
not talk with each other if people want
you know and and such a technology
requires a very good team spirit and and
i think you know when we started innovas
we did like an ocean 11 uh project we
brought like we met with people in
coffee shop coffee shops uh you know
bringing the best mechanical engineer
optical engineer like we really brought
all yeah i can imagine it yeah like
because you know after seven years in
that unit and then three foot startups
you meet so many people
and you say wow if i could bring him
that would be so amazing you know we we
started to reach out to them
and we brought a team that was crazy you
know and there are so many good things
when that happens because you know first
off obviously things you know work very
fast because those are like the top
engineers ever
and also once you bring such a big group
all together from day one you create a
very strong dna
like it's it's like a core
that nothing can really change and when
people come into the company they see
that team they want to be part of it
right and also
no one can really change that dna
because it's already like a very big
call
and you know things go well because
people are very smart and it brings
customer it brings investors yeah
everything right goes in the right
direction it's like a huge
you know power source now if you had to
choose a few words to describe yourself
what would they be
or if i were to ask anybody from innovas
or anybody from bmw or your wifi for
your clients each one each one will
probably say something slightly
different but i would say that
you know we have we are three founders
and each one of us have a different
character we are a different
superhero
okay
i think that um i i bring a lot of uh
i have the the feet of the the
combination of uh
you know vision you know and then
paranoid
because it keeps me up you know i i'm
always trying to understand you know
what can go wrong and understand i
you know i have my partner who is
leading the r d
he organizes a big team and in a very uh
you know he meets he has meetings all
day yeah and understand where things are
and how to try to solve it i'm the guy
that actually goes around the office all
the time and try to talk with people
what's going on what are you working on
what's the problems where are you stuck
and like i'm a problem solver i'm a pro
i i i never go to sleep by the way
before i solve a problem i love it if i
can't find a good problem to solve i i
play sudoku or something but i can't go
to sleep before i feel i solved
something amazing uh so that's the kind
of the combination i i really like to
see i always think further away like
where i want to be even now i have ideas
of where i want to bring this company
forward and those are things that
usually surprises people because there
are so many things we can do
and then it's the the practical kind of
stuff you know to make things that they
you know execution happen and understand
how to solve problems
i enjoy solving problems that's what
they do
this was inspiring i'm sorry that i went
way beyond 20 minutes i just loved it so
much and i really appreciate the time
and and the technology and and you know
really the the most inspiring thing for
me is the very first sentence he said
when i asked you what are you doing and
you the first thing you said was
life-saving which is a little contrarian
to the way that the media and the world
talks about autonomous vehicles or the
priorities of why we're doing autonomous
vehicles obviously that is the priority
and and i just love that that's the
intrinsic motivation that you're after
and thank you for everything you're
welcome thank you